du sable des parasols et des palmiers au
coeur de paris depuis ce matin les quais
de seine ont pris des allures de côte
d'azur pendant un mois les voies sur
berges seront fermées à la circulation
pour laisser croire aux parisiens et aux
touristes qu'ils sont à la plage
même si la baignade est interdite
reportage pierre-yves salies qui connaît
rien
bon on ne fantasmez pas trop à paris
tout n'est que calme volupté et crèmes à
bronzer le matin seulement
rive droite qui est des dunes on ne se
bouscule pas à 10h du mat et c'est aussi
bien au delà des espoirs ici et là des
barbares la mer il faut venir tôt pour
réserver son transat son petit bout de
sable où sa plage de galets chacun ses
goûts l'espace a beau être gratuit il
est rare
tout à l'heure je voyais une déesse des
gens qui demandaient combien fallait
payer pour s'allonger le chercher là est
le guichet mais les boules pareil on les
a fait ça ces cinq années avant midi il
est de bon ton de faire un peu de sport
aux liens vélo roller escalade
trampoline à mais peu de candidats pour
le bain c'est ainsi la promesse d'un
ancien maire de paris est tombée à l'eau
bouillante si bien alors c'est vrai
qu'ils vivent à givet la non non pas
aujourd'hui non un avis partagé par
quelques milliers de badauds voyager
livre de soleil et de rythme chaloupé
ici c'est une danse colin mayer au bout
du compte il y a plus tôt du monde sur
la promenade des parisiens en milieu
d'après midi on ne bronze pas en toute
intimité
non
regarde un concert ce soir et demain il
fera beau ya pas de raison les transats
sont là jusqu'au 18 ans